hello everyone and welcome to another
most impressive game from the affidavit
grand prix the second leg currently
being played in belgrade it's anish
geary versus nikita vitugov and we will
have a very very enjoyable italian game
so let's dive straight into it anish
with white pieces opens with e4 with e5
knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop to
c4 now the italian game is on the board
bishop to c5 going for the joko piano
and now anish castles that's right uh
knight to f6 and now d3 so now a couple
of uh very well known theory moves d3d6
c3h6 rook to e1 now not not worrying
about knight to g4 because we've covered
that many times uh we have uh just
castles by v2gov and not knight b to d2
uh a5 black prevents white's expansion
on the queen side would be for a4 and
now h3 stopping bishop to g4 uh we have
bishop the e6 now attacking the bishop
and this is a very well known position
that um almost always happens on the
board when a displayed and bishop to b5
is the move that's usually played here
so bishop to b5 makes sense you are
fighting for the center also you are
preventing black from
executing the early d5 because you can
just capture and pick up the e5 pawn so
here anish plays the very tricky b3 it's
not a new move it's been played a few
times but not nearly as close to bishop
to b5
so here black says all right you're not
fighting for the center i can uh
immediately execute the d5 so this is
what vtgo goes for we have d5 e captures
on d5 knight captures and now knight the
e4 attacking the bishop on c5 that's
undefended we're using this for this
very nice tempo of getting the knight to
e4 and now there is a game from 2018 uh
jordan fun forest played bishop had this
position with white his opponent played
bishop to a7 here but here we have
bishop to b6 and it is now already as of
move 12 that we have a completely new
game so so far
uh only uh
giri and uh fun forest went for this
line so we could call it the the dutch
line of the uh of the joko piano so here
we have queen to d2 looks odd uh of
course we have to develop the queen
connect our rooks but you are blocking
your own dark square bishop but that
also means that the bishop will be
developed via the a3 square maybe b2 but
most likely a3 as we will get a nice
attack on the rook here so queen to c8
maybe with ideas of bringing the rook to
d8 but as you'll see the queen might be
somewhat misplaced on c8 you are putting
a lot of pressure on black's king side
so that also uh might be relevant the
knight coming to f4 will put even more
pressure there so maybe there are some
sacrificing ideas here but anish plays
knight to the g3 and now we have f6 uh
defending that e5 pawn but now comes a
move that well is incredibly principled
and if you
uh well it can easily be missed but it's
definitely the right idea here anish
plays d4 and now you are saying okay
what do you do now you've just defended
the e5 pawn with f6 but d4
uh it challenges the center right away
yeah you can't start capturing right now
uh
because after the
queen the d7 which was played in the
game uh if you try capturing right away
then we can just go into a nice capture
fest and after of course rook captures
your f2 pawn is hanging and black wins
the game so let's say rook captures on
f2 that's the game over so instead we
have bishop to a3 first we try to get
the rook away from the file so rook to
f7 has to be played kind of and now
comes rook to e4 a very nice rook lived
by anish later on the rook can maybe be
shifted
to the attack and you could also nicely
double up with rook 8 to e1 and you
don't have to worry about something like
f5 for the moment because you have
knight captures and e5 the queen and the
rook are well uh for the moment a a bit
awkwardly placed uh here we have a4
video wants to capture here on b3 that
will uh get a nice open h a file for the
rook here and now b4 closing of the a
file asking black what do you do so
knight to f4 of course we know that the
knight is coming here and here uh
already you can see that there are a lot
of ideas the the pawn might be coming to
d5 at some point if you're not careful
so here we have bishop captures on e6
removing one of the defenders of the d5
square knight captures and now rook a to
e1 interestingly you could play d5 it
doesn't win a piece but
it's interesting after knight g5 knight
captures h captures uh okay you still
can't capture because the queen on d2 is
hanging but after c4 white has a very
very nice game uh however anish prefers
rook a to e1 doubling up on the e file
makes sense now black can never capture
the knight is hanging here so knight to
g5 and now knight captures on g5 we have
h captures and now b5 uh getting rid of
this knight and of course you don't want
to play something like knight to a7
because that puts the knight on the edge
of the board but knight the e7 isn't all
that great because we're just going to
capture it and after rook captures queen
e2 and how are you defending this
position now in order not to lose
material you have to play something like
rook eight to e8 but still uh black's
position just crumbles uh for example
king h8d captures on e5 and you will not
lose material but after captures
captures into this massive capture fest
in the center of the board look at
black's position here it's completely
busted and it's very unlikely that black
will be able to hold this end of the
knight is uh well the knight's a very
tricky bastard you know jumping all over
the place that's not gonna
be easy so instead after b5 we have
knight to a7 going after the b5 pawn
also the bishop on a3 is undefended you
guys probably realize that from the
thumbnail but that's also where the fun
begins here anish plays h4
and asks um uh vitigo what do you play
here the safe course would be to just
play g4 close off uh
the the gameplay on the king side that
the g pawn is nicely defended and we
take the game from there however v2 go
goes for knight captures on b5 it's uh
well a bit of a more of an active idea
as now the bishop on a3 is hanging but
now comes anish's idea and that is h
captures on g5 and now can you capture
the bishop here is it is it really a
free bishop not so much because if you
capture the bishop on each plays g6
the rook has to be moved rook to e7 now
queen e2 going for queen h5 queen h7 and
how do you defend this with black king
f8 we're going to play queen h5 now you
can't continue running anymore because
this will just be checkmate the f7
square is covered so you have to play
something like queen d5 to be able to
bring the queen back to g8 but now we
play d captures on e5 and well let's say
rook 88 you want to put some pressure
here uh e captures on f6 even we give up
the queen for the moment okay it's
defended but we will first win a lot of
material here so now this is the threat
uh this is a huge threat what do you
play here we could capture the queen but
it doesn't matter if captures uh on e7
with check we have rook captures and now
we're just going to capture here and
after captures captures we get this end
game where we're up the exchange and in
a completely winning position so yeah
instead after h captures on g5 uh we
cannot go after the bishop just yet we
have to play f captures and g5 first and
now anish plays queen captures on g5
again leaves the bishop
hanging there on a3 and can the bishop
be captured
uh well probably yes but
in practice no it's much much safer to
play knight captures on c3 and we're
gonna show why because after knight
captures on c3
we get this rook captures an e5 move and
now bishop captures on d4 we've removed
the defender of the d4 pawn once rook f5
is played we play rook to e8 as the rook
on e1 is undefended and once we have a
trait here we will just trade off pretty
much everything rook captures not queen
captures because then queen to d8 check
picks up the bishop here so we have to
play king captures on f7 and now after
let's say queen f4 check
we're gonna play bishop back to f6
because the bishop is hanging and now
queen c for check going after the c7
pawn so queen e6 defending queen
captures king g6 now let's say bishop b2
and we get this position where it's
equal material black king is wide in the
open but it's very unlikely that white
will be able to pursue for more than a
draw here uh so this is uh what happens
after knight captures on c3 but vitigo
decided the knight captures on a3 is a
possibility and it probably is but um a
very very difficult to pull off in
practice uh here on each place knight a
rook to h4
the idea of course is queen h5 or queen
g6 followed by queen quinta or even
better queen h5 followed by queen to h8
to checkmate so here rook to e8 uh still
waiting with uh
with the the the defending ideas here on
the king side queen to h5 now
threatening checkmate and of course rook
f6 clearing the f7 square for the black
king knight to e for now now attacking
the rogue bringing the knight into the
game rook f5 attacking the queen here we
have knight to g5 and now you have to
capture the knight and this is what um
nikita does because if you if you try
running away then we play queen g6 and
after king e7 now rook h7 and that's it
there's no defending this it's a game
over regardless of of what you do
uh
if you go king here we just capture and
it's game over both the queen and the
rook are hanging and if you try a
passive idea like rook to g7 then
there's the rook captures on g7 is fine
but also there's g for very very
unpleasant and now not a lot to do now
for this rook if rook to f6 we just play
rook capture sun g7 now rook captures
queen captures and after king to d8
there's queen to h or we could just
capture draw check doesn't really matter
uh it's
gonna collapse uh completely
uh it already collapsed but uh black
will not be able to hold this even for
for a second so instead after knight to
g5 we have rook captures on g5 you have
to play this queen captures on g5 and
now black is almost out of the woods but
you have to play it very precisely here
uh plays c5 and this is where his
downfall begins uh instead of c5 the
correct way to play this is knight to c4
but it's such an odd move to play the
idea is that we want to defend the e5
pawn simply not to allow this rook to
enter the game because now after queen
h5 we're gonna play rook to f8 and now
uh
we
we can do this because the knight is
guarding this and now after let's say
queen h7 czech king f7 queen h5 check we
can even play g6 queen h7 check king the
e8 queen captures on g6 and now queen to
f7 black defended well and now uh no
problems here however after c5 now the
position is completely winning for anish
and he just plays queen to g6
uh and now what do you play now if you
play rook to f8 then queen h7 check king
of seven rook captures on e5 uh you can
choose how to win this it doesn't really
matter a nice rook f4 and it's game over
there's no rook here to to guard and
there's no knight on c4 to guard the e5
square so instead we have bishop back to
d8 attacking the rook here but now anish
just played rook to h7 and he was in
this position on move 32 that nikita got
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here it's a really
really cool position because it's hard
to realize what um
uh what actually is the threat but just
to give you an example let's say white
plays something knight c4 makes sense
you want to keep an eye on the c5 pawn
we play queen h5 guard the f7 square
we're threatening queen a rook to h8
checkmate and once the black king starts
running away d captures on e5 so our
pawn is nicely protected now and also we
are taking away the f6 square from
black's pieces and the ones let's let's
say let's say we play queen to f7 rook
h8 check king to e7 now queen g5 check
let's taking the d7 and now e6 so this
is one way to win the game uh because
you either give up the queen uh or you
play rook captures and then it's a nice
king hunt queen captures here the rook
is no longer defending the bishop king
to c6 we're gonna play queen to c8 with
check
attack the rook twice so the king has to
go back to defend king d5 now we're
going to play rook d1 check and after
king to e4 let's see queen characters on
c5 and now you have the king on e4
surrounded by white's heavy artillery uh
there is no escaping this i know you
guys like it when i finish the game now
so let's say 95 as the knight is hanging
queen to e3 check king to f5 now comes
f4 and once let's say the knight moves
rook h5 check king f6 and now uh queen
to d4 with check king to e7 and now
queen to d8 to checkmate so this is only
one of the lines that works but
all the others are working as well uh
but it's interesting uh of course vtugo
realizes that it's impossible to hold
this and of course it was here that he
resigned the game uh on move32
so another really impressive game uh
thank you guys for for suggesting this
one we'll see what happens in round
three uh i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to freddie flowers and
also a very happy birthday to mihal
srolin and i would like to thank gregory
borko paul and ronald mcgovern for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
video grand prix until it finishes so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day